the author dr. Richard Dawkins who has
written a God Delusion
as well as The Selfish Gene best-seller
dr. Dawkins why did you choose to write
a autobiography at this point I'm
getting all of it and seemed like a good
moment to do so
my mother is 96 and is a very useful
resource for me to go and talk to tap
her memories and it's been a wonderful
experience actually in effect
interviewing her to write the book
seemed like the right time to do it this
this is in fact just the first half this
is up to the age of 35 up to where I
wrote The Selfish Gene which marks a
sort of natural watershed in my life I
suppose and so if they did make sense to
divide it into two books this is the
first one taking me through childhood
school days University early work as a
scientist and after writing a Selfish
Gene at the age of 35 well why was the
Selfish Gene a natural halfway point for
you in a sense
The Selfish Gene changed my life up but
before that I was at an ordinary
research scientist sort of in a white
lab coat
and then after the self-esteem I stayed
on the faculty at Oxford and went on
teaching and went on doing some research
but I became I suppose more of a public
figure writing books for for large
audiences
who were John and gene Hawkins Dawkins
John and gene were my parents they were
my mother is still alive they my father
was a biologist he did botany at Oxford
so his career began rather similarly to
mine we went to the same kind of
schooling so the fee-paying rather
expensive English SWE's Anglican schools
and then he read botany at Oxford where
as I read serology at Oxford he did he
did research I did research then he went
into the British colonial service which
was the thing did in those days you
don't anymore of course and was posted
to Nyasaland which is now Malawi in
Central East Africa
and then was called up it to fight in
the war against the Italians in
Abyssinia and Somaliland and and I was
born around that time my mother was an
art student came a Cornish family and
they had a shared love of wild things
wild flowers made both of the knew all
the wildflowers and so I was brought up
in an atmosphere of scientific inquiry
and and love of nature were you brought
up in the Anglican Church my parents had
no interest in in with religion but -
central Anakin's foods rather difficult
not to we know that but that's again I
think that normally happened it was
quite hard to find a school that wasn't
in some way churchy and when did you
lose that connection
I suppose finally at the age of about 16
when I was at school but I had my doubts
from earlier I think I first of all had
my doubts around the age of about nine
when my mother wanted out to me that
there were lots of different religions
and when I was brought up in was not
hearing the one so when you asked your
parents about religion about God how did
they respond I think my mother told me
the standard sort of Christian stories
as though she believed them which I
think she didn't and then when I went to
school I got it all from school
Richard Dawkins how did the selfish gene
come about as a book well about ten
years before I wrote it in 1966 I was
asked by my boss the Nobel prize-winning
scientist Niko Tinbergen if I would
stand in and give his lectures for him
he was on sabbatical leave and I wrote a
course of lectures in animal behavior
which pretty much foreshadowed the
rhetoric of The Selfish Gene the idea of
immortal genes funding through the
generations discarding a succession of
bodies all that rhetoric was in those
lectures in 1966 and I vaguely thought
at some point I might write it all down
and I finally did so in 1976
when the self-esteem was published but
you can find in The Selfish Gene almost
the same words as as the lectures that I
gave in 1966 so I don't know why delayed
so long I think I actually started to
put not pen to paper but typewriter key
to paper in about 1972 or 73 when there
was a strike in Britain and and so there
were frequent power cuts we called
electricity cups and I couldn't do my
research so I thought well now's the
time to start writing that long a long
promise book because you didn't need
electricity didn't need electricity in
those days a manual typewriter in an
appetite for wonder you talked about
John Maynard Smith yes who is he who was
he
he was a very wonderful man he was a
very distinguished biologist a very
wonderful character students loved him
he was funny
irreverent constantly talking to
students about real work he didn't do
any of the things that professors do
like fuss about where to where the next
grant is coming from anything like that
he just got on with it and his tools of
the trade were pretty much a pencil and
paper because he was a theorist and he
inspired generations of students he
inspired me although I was never
actually his student and many of his
ideas are incorporated in The Selfish
Gene play a big role in The Selfish Gene
after The Selfish Gene was published how
did your life change as a professor did
you become a celebrity professor in a
sense not immediately it's the book did
sell very well and I think it sold well
over a million copies in total it did
cause a bit of a sensation and I did
find myself being invited to do lots of
things which I haven't been before I
suppose I'm talking to people like you I
suppose that that did start to happen
then and I suppose it did it did change
my life and set me on a new course of
writing other other books after that
here in the States
you're quite well known not only as a
scientist but also as an atheist when
did you start writing about that in
earnest The Selfish Gene has um
intimations the tabs and it doesn't turn
conceal the cat and I suppose all my
books I mean the the next book I wrote
for a popular audience which was the
blind watchmaker is all about the
argument from design which is still I
think the dominant reason why most
people will give for believing in a
Supreme Being they will say look at the
world of nature look at the trees look
at the birds over the flowers it's all
too complicated to her about my chance
and of course it is too complicated to
combine pie charts that's not what it's
about it came about by natural selection
which is the opposite of chance and so
the blind watchmaker
it was an attempt to explain that people
and was taken as an atheistic book by
many people in either
I think the subtitle in America was
something like why the evidence of
evolution shows a universe without
designer something of that sort so the
blind watchmaker was at least
interpreted as an atheistic book and all
my other books since then could be
interpreted in the same way the only
book that is explicitly and at length
atheistic is The God Delusion published
in 2006 which is I think that's my
biggest seller in fact that that's sold
more than 2 million copies in in English
and I don't know how many and searches
foreign languages but apart from that my
books haven't been devoted to atheism
and the way that the God Delusion has
Charles Darwin your hero who saved in an
appetite for one indeed yes and Charles
Darwin was a brilliant thinker brilliant
explainer one of the things I find
surprising is that Darwin's idea which
is really so simple and when anybody
should be able to understand it came so
late
it came two hundred years after Newton
and really you might think that knew
what Newton did was was was cleverer
more difficult to think of in inventing
calculus working out optics
understanding gravity the laws of
mechanics the laws of motion these are
all supreme achievements of the human
mind
two hundred years before Darwin there
you can tell wondering why somebody like
new theorists or indeed Aristotle didn't
think of Darwin's really simple but
immensely powerful idea
Richard Dawkins as somebody who's
written about science written about
ideas what was it like to write about
yourself quite difficult I this a cruel
embarrassment factor in writing about
herself and I was persuaded by both
British and American publishers that it
was worth doing is I should do it since
i should overcome that embarrassment
factor I hope it's a good-humoured book
I like to think it's humorous I like to
think there are plenty of laughs in it
and finally I can say I think that I
enjoyed writing it did you end up
enjoying it yes I did what reliving
memories it's not exactly a systematic
history of my life it's more of a
patchwork of memories which actually was
the working title that I had in mind
that I started writing in so they're
kind of random memories but I hope that
random memories are put together in such
a way and I hope a funny way as to
encapsulate her life it'll be in the
books stores in September of 2013 is
this the American cover or is this the
English and American no that's the
that's the American cover and what is
the English cover luckily the British
cover is sideways on view it looks it's
not smiling it's sort of I suppose you
could say it's more
poetic rather than cheerful and it has
me holding up a little jar containing an
insect and gazing at this of this
infants inspecting this this insect why
why different covers why would that sell
in England and I have no idea publishers
have their ways and I actually like both
covers that I'm quite happy to have both
of them out there an appetite for wonder
the making of a scientists Richard
Dawkins is the author it'll be in
bookstores in September of 2013 this is
book TV on c-span to watch more from